we have an update on a story we first
brought to you last week
people are pouring into a tiny village
in south africa after reports that a
large
diamond was discovered there now
government officials say the stones that
those people dug up
are courts a common mineral that's worth
very little
as deborah potter reports the
announcement has done almost
nothing to stop the treasure hunt
for a few days as you can see it's for
real
people could dream i'll just become rich
[Music]
i'm gonna buy cars with their shovels
and pickaxes fortune seekers have been
digging their way to
a better life this past week often
slumping into an exhausted sleep on site
for many it wasn't just the allure of
luxury
it was a necessity life was hard enough
for bricklayer langani mapumulu before
the pandemic
now there is no work at all we are
suffering
but we are trying our best and we are
struggling but you
are trying mapumulu and his family of
five live on a welfare grant of less
than one hundred and thirty dollars a
month
fifteen of those dollars were spent on
transport
to join his sister in kuleko in the hunt
for treasure
have you been sleeping here in your car
yes i'm sleeping
she celebrates every time she finds a
glittering stone
he carries on digging dreaming of
starting his own business
but the arrival of local official peggy
in konyani dashes everyone's hopes
a lot of people here are convinced these
are diamonds no matter what you say
of course they are disappointed but they
know now that
these are quite the official delegation
doesn't stay long
the bad news is left to travel by word
of mouth
if it's not a diamond have to leave this
place
we have nothing else to do just to go
back home
unlike the paul simon song nobody is
going home with
diamonds on the soles of their shoes
just pocketfuls of quartz crystal
and shattered dreams experts will visit
the site over the next week to see if
the courts that has been found
could provide some kind of income for
the local community
for cbs this morning deborah patrati
south africa